[Applause]
[Music]
that's the moment that comedian amy
schumer and her husband
chef chris fisher found out they were
having a boy
that special moment was captured in the
hbo max documentary series expecting amy
so now they're starring in the emmy
nominated thank you very much
food network show it's called amy
schumer
that's how they sing it learns to cook
the show's second season premiere
better than that the show's second
season premiered last night
i can remember my first pina colada i
went on a cruise with my grandparents we
went on one of those like
you're not in the shot don't talk to me
it was one of those like it left from
florida and
you know you go to like the bahamas for
one day ask her where she went on the
gross
i'm already saying where i went on the
cruise
it was so fun like so my first cruise
was with both my grandparents
she gets seasick i do get sick
yes i do get seasick jane i know you get
seasick and you get cars sick
yeah because of the way someone drives
someone on the floor someone on the
floor
amy and craig amy
amy and chris hey chris
are we catching you two at a bad time is
that the marital bed
mr and mrs fisher
this is where the magic does not happen
is chris in the shot no yes chris chris
is in the shot listen
amy before we get started anthony i got
to tell you this story we were at an
event
amy chris and i and i was talking to amy
how are you doing what's going on it was
a saturday night she goes
i'm doing great i'm getting married next
tuesday i said to who she said that guy
over there
she said go ask him so i went over and
said excuse me are you getting married
to amy schumer on tuesday
he goes yes i am that's how i met chris
fisher so here you guys are
let me just say this to you both i love
love love the show because you
clearly have a lot of fun together in
the kitchen and what i like chris is
that the recipes do you do because
you're working with amy
or you're doing it for the rest of us
the the recipes seem to be pretty simple
i made one last night the uh the potato
skins
do you try to keep it simple for us
actually amy comes up with most of the
concepts and then i
have to write the recipe um yeah and
that was news to me too
it's true it is yeah completely yeah
well
we brainstormed she comes up with a dish
and then i have to write the recipe
amy what were your um i was impressed by
you
well i i need some work i need some work
amy
what were your cooking skills your
culinary skills like before you started
sleeping with the chef
what could you do oh my gosh
um i could uh make one meal
a steak potato and spinach and
now i would say i can make two meals
[Laughter]
how did you guys come up with what we we
should say that chris
is actually a james beard award-winning
chef he can actually cook
so i mean he has skills in the kitchen
amy how'd the idea come about because
the show was really really well done
you two have a lot of fun with nanny
jane who's also shooting a lot of the
shooting
and you were nominated for your first
emmy how did it come about
she's been nominated for an emmy before
and won
thank you this is my stage mom
but how'd this idea how'd this idea come
about
the food network reached out they they
reached out and pitched it to us
and um yeah we'd like to take credit for
it but
it was the food network's idea and and
we said sure we're not doing anything
there's a pandemic
so we just happen to be free and we're
going to be home anyway
they they pitched it sort of
open-endedly and then we were on a walk
and we're like what we didn't we
couldn't really figure out what the show
should be and i just said why don't we
why don't i teach you how to cook oh
really
i don't know that sounds nice
chris what happens if amy gets on your
nerves in the kitchen because i would
imagine
she doesn't get on your nerves often how
dare you gail
no i said i said it doesn't happen often
said it doesn't happen often
because listen i just i just keep going
i just keep going with the meal because
that's
you know essentially we have to eat at
some point so i mean we have to it's a
metaphor for life like
you're married you're in a pandemic like
just cook something and eat it and then
go to sleep
i know how is it going for you both
because you have baby gene too in the
house
yes we can see him he's right outside
playing with jane
um it's good you know it's like it's i
think it's a lot easier having
actually having a baby during this
because
the day is so regimented it's you know
it's like
the days are flying by because he keeps
us busy
yeah how does it how does it feel to
having
putting a camera in your own house i
mean i know you're essentially
shooting yourselves but but i mean
you've said you've said before that it
was pretty
weird that you know when you see
yourself uh fighting
on film
[Laughter]
well the real fights got edited out of
the cooking show
oh my god no i mean we're a real married
couple like and then when you're
you're working together and it's like
you have to be you know you both have to
be in a great mood every day
and 10 days in a row and it's like you
don't have the sort of like help that
you normally would
so we um yeah we just you know we
lovingly
bicker right
what time is this show on are we allowed
to make out
you've only got 90 seconds it's okay you
can hold up for just a second but
listen i love the two of you together
during your wedding vows chris you said
amy is the
craziest kindest person you know and amy
said you're the sweetest guy she knows
but it really works you guys have been
very vulnerable about sharing things
that you've been through
you talked about chris being on the
autism spectrum and how you
all work with that do you ever feel
uncomfortable being so open about the
things that you share
in your life fights and all it's very
very sweet and very very
very tender i don't
feel uncomfortable about it do you no
not at all
no i mean i think something's probably
wrong with us
um so there are no personal limits don't
you know it's like
there are no personal limits for off
nothing's off limits
[Music]
i don't think so i mean you know we just
want to
we want to be able to raise our son well
and we want to have fun healthy lives
and other than that
you know if you know if people judge us
it's none of our business nobody's
judging here's to fun healthy lives
you can kiss us all goodbye thank you
guys
thank you for joining us getting up
early i really appreciate you thanks for
having us
i love the show